this is jason miller getter ceo i'm here
with all the valuetainment maniacs
on that one i like
you're the only one that's ever kind of
like not messed it up hey there
valuetainers this is jason miller getter
ceo and i'm here with valuetaining
questions with the media strategist
tell us about getter and how it's going
to change media getter is the all-in-one
free speech app it's the fastest growing
social media platform in world history
fastest ever to one two three now we're
almost up to five million users globally
on the platform well we're changing
things we're taking out political
discrimination from your social media
experience i think over the last two
years we've seen the worst examples of
political discrimination in u.s history
and now we're giving you your free
speech rights back so if you support
free speech and you oppose cancer
culture check out getter what's your
favorite memory from your time with
trump team oh boy i have a lot of fun
memories from the trump team some of
which i can share uh some which i i
can't share so one of the funnest things
with president trump is he likes to you
say bust people's chops uh mr trump then
mr trump before his president's tom
brady's birthday and so the president's
like ooh uh okay well let's call him so
of course he pulls out his phone of
course he has tom brady's cell number so
he calls up and he's like hey tom brady
it's me
calling to say happy birthday you're one
of the greatest great of all times you
won super bowls you can play until
you're 50. there's only one thing in
life that you couldn't win with you
couldn't close the deal with the vodka
and she picked jared not you uh and it's
it must be tough i know it's only time
you've ever lost you ended up doing okay
tom and again he's saying this in a cell
phone message and he's like you did
pretty well obviously gisele is awesome
but she's not ivanka you would agree
with me bunker's probably the greatest
catch in history uh but tom anyways it's
uh great to um great to leave a message
for you i want to talk to you i'll see
you soon and he hangs up and he leaves
that in a voicemail for tom brady and it
was one of the like i didn't know if i
was gonna laugh or cry it was one of the
funniest things i've ever seen what's
your least favorite memory from your
time with the trump team i would
probably say that on election night of
2020 when fox news called arizona for
biden and the the gut shot of that uh
not just because it ended up in the
obviously the disputed results on that
but i would say that the the fact that
fox news was out even in advance of say
cnn or msnbc that was definitely
probably the low point what was it like
managing the campaign against a then
unknown barack obama in 2004. in 2004 i
was a campaign manager for jack ryan
who ran for the u.s senate in illinois
and he won a nine-way primary i think we
want to buy like nine or ten points so a
former goldman sachs partner uh he was a
volunteer teacher hales franciscan
african-american school in the south
side tremendous guy remained good
friends with him to this day
then when he made it into the general
election against obama we're only
head-to-head for i'd say maybe two
months and then jack ended up dropping
out of the race so during that two-month
stretch we kind of had our own swirl
going on but um i don't know that jack
would have necessarily beaten obama in
2004 it's a blue state presidential year
uh but i don't think that obama would
have come out unscathed and being viewed
as kind of the golden boy right enough
to do the democratic convention all
these things
so my all of my friends blame me for
barack obama becoming president so bring
it on folks i'm ready for all the i'm
ready for all the pilers on
do you have any tattoos no why not i'm
too chicken i just uh the other thing
too is i changed my mind on things and
let me give you a perfect example if i
got a tattoo in the 90s i 100
would have gotten the barbed wire tattoo
around my biceps well guess what i'm not
my biceps don't look like they did in
the 90s what's on your playlist
mac miller right now who do you want to
play you in the movie of your life
uh
you know what i'm i'm pretty humble
let's just say the rock
is it okay to take your shoes off on a
plane
no no that should be should open up the
door and just chuck them out come on
have some classy i agree who do you
disagree with politically but respect
anyone who's passionate in their
convictions um that bernie sanders uh
disagree with him politically on a lot
of things but i very much respect the
the populist attitude that he brings uh
i think that he's someone who's i think
actually believes the stuff that he says
some of it i think the goals and
intentions are good so it's a little bit
crazy uh but you know he probably says
the same thing about me do mermaids have
babies or lay eggs
i have no well hold on there's that
little mermaid i have kids they watch
the stuff as soon as that goes on that
means i can watch whatever on my own
ipad
i've never seen a little mermaid
actually i think there's more i think
there's a little mermaid too so lay eggs
or have beef
i was trying to dodge
i'm trying to i have no i don't know how
this stuff works who would win in a bar
fight between mike pence and bernie
sanders physically um pence is obviously
a much stronger guy he's in good shape
um he's you know he's
he's he's well put together but bernie's
a crafty guy like bernie's the kind of
guy who um like you know you'd expect
him to pull into these moves where like
throws the peanut shells at your face
and then smashes you over the head with
the with the glass or bernie would be
the kind of person that had like a you
know another person to jump out and then
becomes a two on one bernie's crafty i i
don't know i just and bernie their thing
too bernie for sure bites and pulls hair
um uh i think pence would like you know
pence would do like the traditional
fisticuffs like you'd fight them like a
true gentleman and i think
bernie would just get would just get
nasty
follow-up is would pence even ever be in
a bar
uh yes but they
maybe a bar and grill
do you sing in the shower
no comment
bugs could scream before you kill them
would you still do it oh yes i hate bugs
if you could have dinner with any
historical figure who would it be and
why it changes all the time i think
muhammad ali would be
the person right now just got done
watching a big chunk of the muhammad ali
series on pbs
the documentary just such a fascinating
character i think it'd be and also too
just to probably steal some of his lines
uh the guy was just so gifted and so
talented so right now i'm saying
muhammad ali what do you say to the
people that say it's suspicious that you
and alex jones have never been in the
same room at the same time
uh we have appeared well hold on best i
can do i have appeared on his show
um and so you could see that i had the
facial hair uh he did not have uh the
facial hair
so it's clear that we're not the same
person
but um but the one thing i will say on
alex which is great because he's like
you know big huge guy he's got the the
sweet tank and all these things um is
that we were texting after i appeared on
the show and he used a guy with a
barbell emoji and i just thought that
was perfect alex jones and so every time
i think alex jones i'm like that's the
guy with the bar well thank you guys
very much for tuning in all the
valuetainers out there um this is a
great uh experience to be with you all i
would encourage you to check out getter
uh it's a really cool platform the
functionality is great the user
interface is great not only do we have
the micro blogging that competes with
twitter and facebook we have a live
streaming where many of your favorite
people in the us and all around the
world are putting out broadcasts we just
launched get our vision which is our
short video clips to compete with tick
tock and instagram reels and guys when
we launch get or pay this summer in
order to have a two coin crypto
ecosystem not only to compete with
google pay and samsung pay and apple pay
and all this we're going to introduce
the wonders of the digital economy in
crypto and blockchain to all sorts of
people and this is going to be really
cool so getter ge ttr it's in the apple
store it's in the google play store it's
at getter.com come check it out
[Music]